anybody who's in sales will understand
that it's not the words the words are 10
of it like I could give you Chris Rock's
entire routine and you could read it and
it would probably bomb it's all about
the delivery getting them to practice
the proper tonality at the right points
where do I where do I lower my voice so
you think this is more important right
and where do I absolutely totally
understand where am I going to say
something an obvious statement to embed
a belief of something that's really
positive but I'm going to say to so it's
obvious and a preconceived like notion
that you should obviously know yeah
right yeah and so where where am I going
to use these different tonalities to
different parts of the script so that I
can be more persuasive this is just a
practice so every morning the sales team
gets up I can show you my phone I have
up up up up up at four o'clock and five
o'clock in the morning when they all
wake up together and they practice first
thing before they you know think about
their wives before they think about
their kids they practice for an hour and
I think part of that's also setting the
intention for the day of like I'm a
closer I'm here to I'm here to close I'm
here to make sales and I'm not here to
take orders I'm here to order people
they're like you guys wake up at four
it's like
yeah you don't there's no way you're
gonna beat us yeah